alors c'est elie et tu sérieuses le
donjon de la testostérone pas le droit
d'inviter une fille dans un appart comme
le nôtre bon tu lui ouvrir la porte
elle parlera sûrement pas de xbox et moi
je vais être ici à me dire oh j'ai envie
de péter mais je peux pas là je dois me
retenir
j'espère que ses amis sont veille où la
porte je m'en fous je vais me saouler la
gueule
sénat comme la cimade rachidi chocolat
comme un mal propre norme besoin la
copine m'a laissé tomber tu te prends
pour widgets jose da mois c'est le recul
le petit hall mois la casse et on sort
ce soir tu es célibataire on sera
célibataires comme toi ouais vous voulez
le mans ça goûte pas la menthe du tout
c'est une pilule pour bander il me reste
quatre heures pour boire comme qui
trichent 'les et m'éclater
vous avez pas encore trouvé de filles
pour m non quoique rien dit que c'est
plus difficile que tu croises c'est le
moment où on va chez toi parce que je me
sens pas vraiment assis sur mon mentor
tu l'as lu fille au bar qui te regardent
vous ne désirez pas le faire tout de
suite pour te sers attendre au moins 40
jours quand tu te feras tendre aussi
puis j'ai réalisé que moi je suis un
gars
on n'est pas censé les voir plus que
deux fois par semaine et toi tu vois
cette fille deux fois par jour mais
qu'est ce qui se passe entre 3 et
chelsea
qu'est ce que vient faire ici
bordel de l'écouter c'est pas du tout ce
que vous pensez c'est quoi alors ah
d'accord alors qu'est-ce que je dois
penser notre relation attends tu veux
dire que vous êtes un coup j'essaie de
faire comme si rien n'avait changé
allez approche vraiment t'approche pas
sentons panther d'accord ce spectacle
être prudent quand l'autre a besoin de
toi
tout simplement ça le sens d'une
relative
son rire j'aime la façon dont encore
fusionnent au lit on est de la même
taille alors nos forces sont à la même
enseigne manque ou château ça se
comprend et parfaite à l'évaluer d'y
arriver de suite pas de lui dire par
action au nom
c'est qu'il idiot tu utilises
l'autobronzant c'est moi en tout cas je
croyais c'était de la lotion alors quoi
non ma cure et orange
on dirait un conte de construction je
dirais plutôt une girafe triste